hello and welcome to the fourth part of
our tkinter tutorial within python 3.
where we left off we have a window that
we can generate
and it looks like this and we can resize
it close minimize all that and we can
hit quit
and we are able to actually exit the
window
now what we want to add really is on
most windows you have you know this like
menu bar here and you can hit file and
then exit so
the exit button that we built was mostly
just for show of you know how you make a
button how you can event handle with
that button and it just so happens that
a quit button is one of the easiest ones
to program so that's what we've done but
really we're actually probably gonna
more more likely want to have a file
exit so i'm gonna go ahead and comment
these out and then what we're going to
do in this video is actually make
a kind of
a main menu
and have file and exit in that menu so
now with that let's go ahead and get
started so
we'll just comment this quick button out
we don't really want there anymore and
let's go ahead and make uh our menu so
this might get a little confusing i'd
like to confuse myself on these steps as
well so sorry if i do that in
so
under our define init underscore window
self
function here this is where we're going
to add our menu so our menu is actually
going to be a part of our main
window frame or
mainframe um so that's where we want the
menu to be and then we want to obviously
you know put all the little parts to
that menu on that menu and so the way it
really works usually is you kind of go
not really top down but maybe down to
the top so so first you define
you know you you're going to define your
to let's say you want a menu bar that
goes you can go file exit on you're
going to define the exit which you're
going to append to the file which you're
going to append to the main menu bar
which will be appended to the mainframe
okay so it gets kind of sticky like that
to think of it that way but that's
pretty much the way it goes so
let's go ahead and get started so first
we're going to say menu lowercase menu
equals capital m menu
um and then we're going to say
self.master and basically what we're
saying here is we're saying this is the
menu of the main window okay
then we're going to say
self.master.config and we're going to
say the menu here equals this menu that
we've just defined so we're defining
that
the instance of the menu so far
and this is so we can start adding
things to the menu and then we can place
the menu
on there now it might get a little
confusing uh menu capital m is a
reference to something that's built into
tkinter okay lowercase menu is something
we're just making up so don't get too
confused remember lowercase m menu is
arts capital m menu is something that is
a part of decanter also this is probably
bad practice but i can't think of a
better name than menu so we're going to
get away with that so self.master um
or self.master.config menu menu so we've
defined the menu now we want to create
our file object right so when we go i
guess i'll just leave this down here for
now so when we go here we have to make
something that is this file button right
so we're going to say
file equals capital menu
menu
menu so it's a menu file as part of our
menu menu
and then we're going to say file dot add
underscore command
and this command that's a part of our
file menu so like we hit file and then
we've got all these things here right
these are basically commands right new
file open recent files open module class
browser save print exit close whatever
these are commands basically so now what
command do we want to add well we're
going to add label equals we're going to
add an exit okay so that's kind of an
integral part of your file and if i'll
quit file exit
and then we're going to say the command
for this so
kind of remember our button where we
said you know our label was you know
whatever
um or command equals what and so our
command here is equal to self dot client
underscore exit so that's referencing
this function that we made a while ago
okay so that's our exit
now we want to add basically we've got a
command added to file now we want to add
file
to our menu so we're going to say menu
dot
add underscore cascade so this is you
know like this is your cascade right you
hit file and it's like this cascade of
options so menu dot add cascade
uh label equals file
and then we're going to say the menu
that we're adding
here right the menu that we're adding
the menu is
uh
file so this
so as you can see we've got menus and
menus here so it's like many many menu
but anyway
um
so menu equals menu menu
interesting so
uh so we've added we've got our exit
we've got a file and now we want to do
is like let's say
um
we could just we probably we could
probably get away with this for now so
let's go ahead save and run this let's
see if we've screwed anything up so far
okay good so we've got a file you click
this we've got an exit you can hit exit
you'll probably get this little warning
here for killing the script but yes okay
so we've got a file in our exit works
now
what i like to do in a tutorial like
this especially where we've got a menu
is
it's one thing to create like one little
button and then one thing that you can
do in that button but it's another thing
to like add one more so this might make
a little bit of sense to most of you
guys but it might still be really
confusing so uh i think probably the
most helpful thing to do at this point
is to make one more menu item so the
next item that typically we have is an
edit right and here we have edit undo
okay so why don't we add an undo okay or
an edit undo
so we've got that and now what we want
to do is we're going to go back down
here so
if you recall we've done basically this
is
what we created for a file button right
and then from that or to that file
button we added an exit and what it that
exit did right
um and that's what we do with these
three lines but these three or these two
are just defining the menu where that
menu goes and all that uh and then it's
part of our main window so now let's go
ahead and add
edit so here we go edit equals and then
menu
menu so it's part of our main menu then
we're going to go edit dot add
underscore command
label equals
um
undo okay so
we're not going to really have anything
to undo so i'm not going to add a
command to this but as you can see where
we've got edit we add the command that
we want to edit because if we added edit
first and then try to change it it
wouldn't necessarily uh
you would almost be displaying the edit
before you've actually made the change
so it's kind of like in in
well i haven't really covered matplotlib
but if you're familiar with matplotlib
we've covered it in python27 anyway
wait the way it works is first you draw
something and then you display it
okay so if you if you draw it display it
and draw some more you have to read
display okay uh you know dot show you
got to redo dot show
uh in order to see the difference okay
so it's a lot like a window where you
want to make
exactly what you want add it and then
show the window and it'll be there but
if you first add you know let's say file
to the window then you try to add the
file it works it doesn't really work
that way it's not a good idea to do it
that way so anyway edit.add command undo
we're not going to throw in a command
because we just don't have a command to
do
um
and
or yeah like literally you know you add
command to
edit right but that edit or really
basically we're not adding a command to
undo so it's really confusing when i say
add command but and then we're saying
we're not adding a command but whatever
anyway
edit dot add command and then we're
going to say menu dot
add underscore cascade
and then what are we going to add
the label is going to equal
edit
and the menu
is going to equal
um
edit that we're adding basically so
we can save that let's run that
and we get this right so we've got file
we can click exit we've got edit we can
go undo okay
so now we've got these two little
buttons here and you can basically see
the pattern that we go through so let's
exit this
you can see the pattern that we go
through to add buttons right this is to
add your button now we could actually
just do this right if we just if you
just simply wanted to add a button right
so
none of these buttons do it but say help
led to maybe a web page or something you
could just do you know something like
this right and now you've got the button
but you don't actually have anything
that you know pops down from that button
um
but anyway we've got that and so you can
see basically how you add a button if
you only have one option it looks just
like this just three things now we could
add commands to
the buttons so we could do something
like file
um
maybe something like this so what if we
just added one more line
label and instead of exit we want to
have save the command we'll just leave
as client exit just for now just for
example purposes so we can save and run
that and we've got file and now we've
got save exit now of course when we hit
save it's going to exit
so we'd want to you know change the
function but that's how you can continue
just adding things to your menu so
really making the making of a menu
object you just you know say where
you're going to put it you're going to
add commands or you know things that you
can do with that and then at by the time
you're all done with that you add that
cascade to the menu okay
so
that's going to conclude this video if
you guys have any questions or comments
regarding this video feel free to leave
them below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time